I heard you had some interesting news
today I don't know what it is I just my
producer came out beforehand she said
that you had kind of an interesting day
I called your producer on the way here
in the car cuz I was very excited I
found out I did one of those genetic
testing things yeah and I found out that
I'm 63 percent Irish are you really
you had no weight you had no idea that
you were that Irish I had no idea yeah I
had no idea I thought I was Scottish and
Welsh right well that's so it turns out
my parents are just full of [ __ ] they
just made that out but now I'm Irish it
just makes so much sense I'm a really
good drinker yeah I'm looking forward to
meeting all my cousins yeah no no you
don't want to meet those people no you
and I are probably related yeah
Yeah right no let me say something say
things like it's in me genes genes so
nice the people I'm related to Conan
O'Brien
[Laughter]
[Applause]
giant leprechaun you know I had genetic
testing done Lisa Kudrow got me to do it
cuz she has that show yeah she said do
it and she I'd never done it before and
she told me I think like three months
ago she said oh this won't we find out
about about me was that I am 99.8% Irish
99.8% Irish maybe a record I do think I
think I'm more Irish than people living
in Ireland put you on the flag yeah no
no I looked into it I was like that
means I'm inbred That's not me
you